- Technology has improved
so much of our lives.
You can order something from 15 miles away
and have it delivered in 15 minutes.
You can talk to someone across
the globe in five seconds.
But we have to ask ourselves,
with so much that we gain,
what is it that we're losing?
(cash register ring)
It's becoming increasingly more likely
that when you visit a fast food restaurant
or a grocery store that
instead of a person
checking you out, it'll be a machine.
Self-serving and check-out
kiosks are becoming common.
And even replacing
cashiers in certain cases.
Could this mean that this
profession as we know it
might cease to exist?
(plane engine)
Will the ease of online booking,
the necessity for a travel agent
has all, but disappeared.
(newspaper crumpling)
Now that you can get all the news you want
at just the touch of a finger,
why would you need a newspaper?
But what does that say about the paperboy?
Or a book publishing house?
Or even the printing press?
(camera snap)
It wasn't so long ago
that you could walk into
any one of your neighborhood drugstores
and find somewhere to
process 35 millimeter film.
But with the rise of digital photography,
it's becoming increasingly harder to find.
(car engine)
Self-driving cars are expected to work
without the necessity of a driver.
General Motors and lyft are
reportedly joining forces
and will work on building a
network of self-driving cars.
GM will reportedly invest
$500 million in lyft.
With the recent advent
of self-driving cars,
what does that say about Uber,
lyft, or even taxi drivers?
Does that mean they'll
become obsolete as well?
(quiet dramatic music)